all right up next and this was one of
the deals that was facilitated by the
new cba being put in place ryan
tannehill staying put with the tennessee
titans four years 118 million dollars 62
million guaranteed at signing a total of
91 million or thereabouts that will be
fully guaranteed by the fifth day of the
2021 league year a great deal almost 30
million per year for a guy who who had a
hot potato contract last year where the
dolphins had to pay part of it to unload
him onto the titans chris
yeah no i know it is a great deal uh are
quarterbacks overpaid yes but you know
this is the way it is right now in our
current nfl market the going price for
starting quarterbacks you know he
certainly has done more than jimmy
garoppolo did to justify his 27 and a
half million dollar a year contract a
few years back so we can say that right
off the bat let alone
you know i think ryan can hill is really
just a perfect fit for how the tennessee
titans want to play football i mean they
want to play ball control they want to
take shots down the field you know and
then within that yeah the offense isn't
always going to be this overly creative
greatest show on turf type play they
need a quarterback who can move and make
plays off schedule let alone we know
they want to run derrick henry and do
that and ryan tannehill is very athletic
to have his own run game that can
you know make it harder on defenses
schematically with the read options and
some of the quarterback design runs so i
think he really fits their skill set let
alone he's in the prime of his career
he's much better player than people have
ever given credit for and i think all
those are the reasons why the tennessee
titans realize that a guy like ryan
tannehill was a better fit than tom
brady
they're giving him 62 million for the
first two years when you look at the
signing bonus and the salaries do you
think they ever were serious about
pursuing tom brady when you see that
kind of commitment to ryan tannehill
uh i i don't i think that they probably
john robinson mike brabel them being
from new england i'm sure they tossed
around the idea a little bit you know
even with ownership it is tom brady he
could like nashville on fire as far as
excitement goes
i would think they thought about it a
little but again
you know the risk reward to bring a guy
in who's 43 years old uh who might only
be there for one year or let's say he
pulls a hamstring in week one of the nfl
season you know then you're gonna cut
and everyone's gonna be like you didn't
sign a good backup you're stupid he's 43
years old i mean how did you not expect
that so i think all of those things and
just realizing how talented ryan
tannehill was the year he had and
everything yeah it makes me believe that
it was thought about but i don't think
it was real real serious there in
tennessee and another thing i like about
this deal chris look it pays out real
money with that 91 million over the
first three years which is a practical
matter will be fully guaranteed they're
not going to cut him after one year and
let him walk away with 62 million
subject to an offset so he's getting 91
million over three years there's only
one dummy year on the back end that
isn't guaranteed they didn't insist on a
six-year deal and that's good for
tannehill he'll get back to the market
after four years or force a
restructuring or an extension before
then a lot of times you see deals that
pay out this much money you've got those
phony numbers on the back end where the
team controls the player not the other
way around and you know aaron rodgers
your your all-time favorite quarterback
he always does those ultra long-term
deals there's an argument to be made to
cut them off and that's what tannehill
did cutting it off at four years without
being controlled by the titans for year
five and year six i i think my good i
mean
i'm glad you brought it up because i
think that was probably the most
surprising thing to me about the
contract you know
um yes it's great for players and ryan
tannehill that he's putting the pressure
on the team the market everything like
that
uh but i thought maybe he would take a
hair more of a team-friendly deal to
make it five or six years just to lower
that per year number um but obviously
tennessee was very comfortable and i
think that speaks loudly to how good
they feel about what they saw from ryan
tannehill this year you know and again i
hear people you know go well they didn't
even have to throw the ball that much in
the playoffs okay you know i get it but
it wasn't like they were avoiding
throwing the ball like we saw in the
second half with jimmy garoppolo against
the minnesota vikings you know the
baltimore ravens game he came out made a
lot of big throws then they just got a
cushioned lead to where they said okay
let's drop back we don't think baltimore
can throw the ball every play and beat
us let's just run the ball and run this
clock out it wasn't like they were like
oh no we're so scared of what ryan
tannehill might do and let's phase him
out of the game plan i think people got
to remember that too he threw two big
touchdown passes deep down the field
early on in that ravens game that gave
them the lead
to then allow them to play a more
conservative style
117.5 passer rating fourth highest
single season
passer rating in league history and yes
he only started 10 games but the titans
knew after studying him for a full year
and the other thing about tom brady
chris you mentioned john robinson the gm
of the team mike vrabel the coach of the
team look they have access to the same
film that the the rest of the league
does and they were able to look at it
and come to a conclusion that father
time may be beginning the process of
whacking tom brady over the head with
that giant hourglass and or the sickle
or the scythe or whatever the hell it is
he carries around his staff whatever it
is he's he's closing in on
winning
tom brady like the rest of us eventually
will lose to father time and uh it could
be they looked at the film chris and
decided now's the time to not make the
investment in tom brady
yeah i i think that's very real you know
again i will go back and then you know
just we talked about the formula in
which the tennessee titans play
and yes i don't think that's con
conducive
to a guy like tom brady at 43 years old
i don't where hey we want you to stand
in the pocket and let aj brown work
downfield to throw 20 and 30 yard passes
down the field and you might get crushed
doing it you know that what is what i
would say and i know some other
evaluators out there in the nfl too
would be the one thing that jumps out
about brady and his play on film is i i
think there's a real question of whether
he's willing to stand in the pocket
and make big throws down the field and
take the punishment that comes along
with that and that's why i question
whether the tampa bay buccaneers and
bruce arians will work with brady as
well to further that point because as we
know
i mean that's what bruce arians expect
you say it a million times you know no
risk it no biscuit and that means you
don't stand in there and make big throws
uh then you're not gonna get that
biscuit and i don't know if tom brady is
uh willing to play that style of
football at this point of his career
he'll say i don't want a biscuit i don't
eat biscuits that's what he'd say
all right
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports